bravant le froid près de 150 personnes
se sont rassemblées ce matin à dole pour
dénoncer la série de mesurettes
annoncées par le président de la
république on sait qu' il ya une énorme
majorité de la population qui est
derrière nous qui soutient sa qui veut
une augmentation du cours d'achat qui
veut que les retraités plus vivre
dignement qui veut que le smic soit
augmentée on a un exemple de 20 pour ce
22 % en espagne et bae
pourquoi c'est pas possible ici ans en
france et il y en a marre de ce
gouvernement de ses gouvernants et puis
dans les gouvernances mais bien les
actionnaires des multinationales qui ont
permis l'élection de macron et qui
maintenant en bas en tire un subside
très important ensemble cgt fsu et gilet
jaune pour une convergence des
revendications et de la lutte
un espoir un peu déçu ce matin par la
faible mobilisation